from the studio they could really use a
new franchise now the divergent crashed
and burned onto TV comes the reboot that
asks what if we took the Power Rangers
seriously Oh Power Rangers if you love
The Breakfast Club but which the
alternative ninjas at the end then this
is the movie for you as these teenagers
stuck in detention spend 90 minutes
bonding with each other I'm Zack and I
am a Power Ranger followed by a generic
30-minute episode of the Power Rangers
TV show man I wish they'd kept the focus
off the robot battles and on to the
Power Rangers family issues what's tree
gonna say to her parents is sex mom I'm
gonna be okay and what time line am i
living in where these are the questions
I have about the Power Rangers forget
everything you know about Jason Zack
Kimberly Billy and Trini except their
names because these five teenagers have
so much attitude you'll swear adults
just put random edgy traits out of a hat
like death metal yoga lesbian cliff
diving cheerleaders sexter whoa
trailer park asian wild card hobo
[Music]
autistic black country music loving
hacker I love country music and the guy
who doesn't want to play football why
not go with that bully that looks like
Ed Sheeran or at least Jason's friend
who jerked off a cow how did you smoke
there him now that's Ted
fan favorites or Don will return thanks
to half a day in a vo booth with Bryan
Cranston you need me he's here to do two
things
John loads of exposition on the audience
Power Rangers world
aegeon of warriors sworn to protect life
you must become those warriors and
okay's a leader to do one thing she will
create gold are a huge monster who will
rip the crystal from the earth and all
life on together the Rangers will battle
Rita Repulsa a fresh new take on Austin
Powers Goldmember she's got a plan to
destroy the world and it all centers
around the most blatant product
placement in movie history is a Krispy
Kreme
this is a special place hmm I could
really go for some dunkin right now so
gear up for a movie that's more than a
remake of a kid show because buried
under its many cheesy moments this is
the minimum well I was the best cheesy
looking Zords and cheesy message about
how the real Power Ranger was inside you
all along we do get armor you already
have it inside of here lies a really
good high school drama that's worth
exploring in a sequel maybe one about
them rebuilding angel Grove because they
really messed that place up
why are you cheering your town is in
ruins
starring varsity Reds pinky in the plane
sack in black really the first case
super here in a movie
Wow fill shy the science guy lady Loki
Walter White crawler silly putty's and
Angel gross hottest club is III it's got
everything floating heads morphing grits
and five teenagers of attitude crispy
creamy Power Rangers
hey look it's the white power ranger
wait white power ranger that don't sound
right I am Diana of the mascara daughter
of Hippolyta and your wrath upon this
world is over I didn't choose the epic
voice life the epic voice life chose me
tis I the freshest fry have you ever
heard the tragic of Darth Plagueis the
wise behold the legendary powers of my
burrito